[Music]
oh let's do it [__] let's talk yeah how
you guys doing hey hey good to be here
I'm wiped yeah me too man travel all
that [__] Soul Joes last night two shows
which he guilted me into a benefit on
Thursday cuz I'm doing the punchline
this weekend it's going to be worth it I
get more work done in that room than
than any club in the country it's just
he makes it easy the can't work out a
benefit no benefit I'm enough for sheet
of paper yeah [__] you what do you guys
yes what is it cancer who cares what is
this the Golden Globes sorry to the
people on The Client List already a
Golden Globes we didn't even make it a
minute Well's going to throw his Riders
under the
bus but yeah yeah did that see it's a
two and a half hour drive so you get
back then he got the Seinfeld breakfast
he's got to be there at 9:00 in the
morning so then you got to get 9:00 a.m.
9:45 yeah that's not awful no not bad
but uh a few years ago that would have
hurt oh yeah but we we're getting older
great pick oh yeah we he really he could
he's rocking a long scarf I know and we
had that great moment where he would put
it on and then we'd start talking again
he would take that puppy right off and I
was like we're back in damn that's good
yeah we did about an hour 40 minutes
like a prostitute throwing your jacket
on yeah she getting her back exactly
love it yeah we really we got into it we
chopped it up we covered everything any
any hot nugs you can share well I don't
want to kiss and tell but uh we did wa
hold on let me let me see that finger ah
smells like a bagel but we did theoy we
did the Cat Williams we did all the
specials we did uh you know Nate Gaza
marriage kids the whole thing I don't
know what's that or the Gaza the
marriage but either way we talked about
everything either way you're a
hostage yes speaking of hostages let's
talk about the Golden Globes no yeah man
that was tough that was tough oh
actually I did bring up a Golden Globe
clip CLI here hey he didn't have a bad
set he was gaffan killed it this was
awesome and it's awesome to see him go
kind of blue
yeah Golden
Globes I mean
I I can't even believe I'm in the
entertainment
industry I can't I you know it's so
unlikely I'm from a small town in
Indiana I'm not a
pedophile that came out of nowhere too
that was great great great line it's
like uh that's kind of what you got to
do I mean it's also from Ham it's so uh
it's such unexpected yeah it's so
unexpected but what's great about Gavin
and look Coy is a you know ky's a killer
he does Arenas he's got his own fans
he'll be fine but it's a is a different
gig and this is straight up a hell gig
hell gig it is a hell gig it's a gig
where you like you look at that crowd
you're like they're nervous yes the way
we talk about colleges where they're
like these kids are nervous to laugh now
cuz they feel like maybe complicit yeah
they don't want to let it's also such a
weird ritual to just be like Paul
giamatti's here then you zoom in on Paul
giamatti's face it doesn't work it's cuz
it's not a roast exactly it's but then
it kind of is but it is and then like
you kind of can't go that hard cuz it's
so it's like you have to be mean but in
a clean way yes it's a tough line yeah
you got to you got to tap dance on that
tight rope but he's not that guy he's
not the joke guy but also he didn't say
who he was Gaffin comes up and goes what
am I doing here I'm ug I'm Midwestern
I'm fat whatever he established kind of
who okay I I'm paraphrasing but he he
kind of like hey here I am isn't this
weird where Koy just came out and went
Taylor Swift what's up with that [__]
huh nice bad I wish gaffan started doing
the The Voice the audience voice did
this guy just call us all
pedophiles this guy's destroying his
career he just kept going that would
have been great dude I yeah you're right
you got to open when you roast you got
open self-deprecating at this type of
event not an actual roast of course but
like at this type of event you got to be
like who the hell am I yes I don't
remember if D did that because he
doesn't have to he already he's a pretty
big star I think he went with I don't
give a [__] yeah that's what he said he
said I don't care about this this uh
event tonight he goes I'm GNA air it out
and he just aired it out yeah 10 days
notice is crazy that's that's pretty
soon Daddy got 10 days notice I mean
that is but also like I don't mean to be
a dick I thought about it I'm like I'm
calling JP McDade I'm calling of course
on hburg I'm calling like some joke
people we're going to get on a zoom call
we're going to bang out a shill out of
jokes yeah I think 10 is enough it's
doable it's definitely doable but also
we've all bombed but to be a headline
bomb that I would be in the shower
holding my knees like I don't know what
good comes from that but I guess like if
you crush you're like he although I will
say one good that comes from this he's
got a new 15 20 minutes out of this yo
definitely true cuz it is that's
self-deprecating so I bomb the Golden
Globes that's a funny start like already
people are like all right give me some
stories what's worse getting slapped I
knew you're going to say that live on
television as a host of the Oscars or
bombing your opening at the Golden Globe
I'd rather slap yeah I think because the
slap you're the victim and has nothing
to do with your act we got slapped after
a joke true true I agree I would rather
be slapped I think yeah cuz it's not a
bomb it's an event it's it's a spectacle
but it ain't a bomb
this guy's known for bombing now or
known for a bomb not known for bombing
he he he's a big act but he'll be fine
he's huge yeah that's what I mean it's
part of me is like we talk all about
this cancelling and all that but like I
feel like people don't go away no
especially not Comics yeah because you
do have like now people will want to
hear about this people are going to want
to know okay what happened at the
Afterparty who snubbed you who you know
who who was cool right right you know
like there there's stories there so and
now he's a household name even though
it's not the name sake you want known as
the guy who had a rough set but my mom
didn't know who he was and now she does
yeah it just sucks to be known for a bad
set I know cuz it it could have been any
of us like that that is the thing like
but I do miss the kind of
like I think he got it because of his
how big he is because he's a huge act
but I do miss it when it was like joke
people sure you know like kind of like a
Gary Shanley would host them back the
day or you get like a Jas you know yeah
but I think they they did about 11 calls
and then they got to him I think they
want the Shand Lings of world how about
uh good luck that's a tough ass how
about uh how about Gaffigan yeah I don't
know I bet he said I bet he doesn't want
to do it because it's a hell gig so he's
like dude I'm doing all these crazy
theater runs with Seinfeld I'm doing
Arenas I don't want to go right for the
Golden Globes and maybe bomb it's a bad
crowd and you see like I didn't watch I
you know I saw Clips but I was watching
like you know dairo kind of gave him
like like I want you could tell he's
like a vet he's like I want this guy to
do well I think dairo respects Comics
you know but then there's some people
there like the Taylor Swift moment and
now the Swifty is going after him I'm
like you know really bugs me about the
Taylor Swift audience is like she's
doing well yeah she doesn't need you
every second of the day to be like how
dare you you think that really hurt of
course it was like a it was not a good
joke but it wasn't even like an offense
joke also can we talk about it wasn't
her it wasn't about her no the NFL she's
clearly the most vindictive person on
the planet like every song is about this
guy wronged me it's like well there is a
common denominator here bangs it seems
like it's never you is it she's going to
rhyme Joe Koy with no joy in some song
coming up right right I'm really sad
about it but also Joe is funny and he's
a 30-year comic he's he's been around
where the hell was the Riff I would have
gone like boy Oppenheimer blah blah blah
okay well that bombed too you know some
give me some tap dancing it's tough when
you're live on TV like you know what I
mean like it's one thing to riff in a in
a comedy club or a theater or something
but like I get it live on TV
like it it could get worse true he RI
that line about his writers oh God that
was not that's brutal that was a bad
that was a bad riff bad move bad mov you
don't ever throw the writers because
first off it's like you're watching the
set and you're like this guy had writers
you know what I mean and now you're
throwing them under the bus yeah I think
I a lot of people don't know we have
like like we don't have Riders as
standups but like in award show of
course it's like a short no thing you
have help but uh you know what that felt
like it felt like you ever got in like a
fist fight in high school and one of
your friends runs off and you're like
that [__] we all got our ass
kicked and he ran to the arcade or
whatever that's what that felt like like
it was him it was him it wasn't me and
you're like you red me out in two
seconds yeah but yeah that was tough but
he'll be be fine Coy's a killer he's
he's done the Forum he does all these
crazy gigs so he'll he'll be just fine
and you're right he'll have 20 minutes
on this and that's G to be almost worth
it because that's going to be so fun to
watch that re exactly that's the thing
it's like people are going to want to
hear this yeah I think I think that next
Netflix special wherever the hell it is
you're like damn I heard he's talking
about it yes it's kind of interesting
right slap all over again like the slap
yeah but we got not as interesting as a
slap the slap was insane that was
unprecedented but you got to admit
comedy has never been this big where a
bomb is in a headline and now you got to
go hear about the bomb on this on his
new special like comedy is so huge
Chappelle Chappelle punching down you're
like you know we got a Ukraine war we
got Israel but when comedian tells jokes
you know it's like that's how big comedy
is it's it's it's a little scary Will
Smith could have redeemed himself if he
slapped Joe Koy cuz that might have
saved the set people been like wow this
is kind of interesting you know yeah but
it was so it was rough where like he
came back out and you're like I could
tell like we've all done those gigs
where you're hosting and you have to
come back out and the crowd hates you
and we've never done them when the crowd
is Merill Streep and Robert DeNiro I
know I know it's tough well it's a
battle wound he's got the at the MTV
Awards that time but that was like
warm-up warm-up wasn't televised thank
God but that was like I was crushed I've
taking some tough L's I bombed the friar
Club Roast once when I was 21 and that
[__] hurt oh it hurt it really hurt I
mean it was like an embarrassing cuz I
was a kid I didn't like I didn't I
wasn't ready yeah I wasn't ready to uh I
thought you were pulling up a clip no
don't pull this [__] up what are you
doing it's just me talking about it okay
but and then Norton's trashing me and
Norton goes give me one of the bits I
did and I did it like an idiot and of
course it bombed in the room and then
they all died and it was that was
painful
again you gota you gotta realize Ricky
dvas here his monologue was so it was
more it wasn't even a mon it was a shift
it was a shift in award show monologues
because it changed everything every
monologue now we compare to Ricky that's
how big that mon was and Amy polar were
funny too no no they're great they're
great I think I think what really was
revealing I didn't watch the whole show
I was like dipping in and out cuz you
know there was football on and stuff and
I was kind of like flipping around but
uh I came back and Will Farrell and
Kristen wig were doing they were great I
to me that wasn't funny at all but
that's that's what the
just them like danc it was just such a
like kind of it was they're hilarious
but to me it was the the gag was just so
We Can't Stop Dancing that's the gag
it's like that's what the room wants
they want like for like I don't I'm not
calling them hacks cuz they're brilliant
they're both brilliant but like it's
kind of like a hacky bit it felt Steve
martiny like this is absurd it felt more
Billy Crystal than Steve martiny you
know but yeah but I thought it was it
kind of cut the tension cuz at least it
was it was hitting yeah you know um but
yeah yeah no they're both they're both
both insanely likable and hilarious but
to me it was like a whatever to me this
is like not a bit that was and then you
see some of these actors you're like
they're terrified you know they're like
they're clearly just like well this
didn't work comedy is [__] hard y
that goes to show like these actors like
miss one little line then they're like
[__] it play it straight yep exactly and
I get it you don't want to you don't
want to take that [__] plunge it's it
it ain't fun but hey the beauty of
Comedy we can go back out on the road
and talk about this these actors need to
get tired we got an audience we got a
room full of people who's ready to hear
some jokes these actors need to stay
they can't [__] around we can [__]
around and go talk about it we can make
mistakes and then own it they got to
just hopefully the system keeps booking
them that's a shitty uh position it's
weird cuz I see people on both sides
like the people that are trashing Joe
Koy it's it I think it's pretty lame but
I think also the people that are like
almost two on his side you know yeah
that's weird I saw I saw that too I'm
like I mean it was bad mm the jokes
weren't great they weren't good I think
that's a different muscle I think to to
be a good uh that type of host you need
to be able to be like a good roast
someone who's like I mean Seth McFarland
you could see on like a roast you know
what I mean you could do it I thought it
was weird I saw a tweet it was like
christalia I thought he did great I
don't know what people are talking about
oh he said that yeah he tweeted it well
they sweetened the [__] out of it that
was the problem every I I had a couple
people like I think he's doing all right
he's getting I'm like those aren't real
I know sweeten when I hear it listen to
J it's like God oh there's like specific
moments of people in the crowd this was
just there's no where someone has a
heart attack yeah yeah oh [__] right
that was just two generic like it was
too perfect and they cut to the people
in the audience and they're
like so where's that noise coming from
that really the crossed arms like I just
couldn't watching com IC bomb like at
the seller it's funny cuz we're like all
right he's working out it's kind of
funny when you see a good comic not
connect cuz it's interesting to see what
they do but on a stage that big that
attitude to me really bugs me yeah that
attitude of
like [__] you yeah you know how hard
this is or maybe they don't know how
hard it sucks it sucks it sucks that he
bombed of course I mean I'm not saying
the jokes are good but it does suck yes
it sucks that he just ate [__] he after
that M he went in that backstage J was
like what the [__] oh my God he's
covered in sweat he's got to wipe down
he's like it's like a car crash you have
to like regroup it's also a weird like
you're not one of us
type where it's like I would argue his
journey for lack of a better word you
want to call it was harder of course so
the whole like you're not one of us that
this is why America doesn't feel
connected to actors that arrogance you
you being like what we do is harder [__]
off it ain't it ain't and and and all
they talk about is inclusivity well let
that guy in how about that exactly if if
you want to be like you know we need to
think about LGBT what about a a a
performer they're not one of you what
about an Asian
man Nagasaki huh all right but yeah more
like
Nagasaki the reviews are in uh haima
okay but uh yeah I know that's what bugs
me is the whole like everything's about
inclusiveness and then and then you see
how they treat a comedian I know exactly
and I agree that I'm saying the jokes
are bad but still like just that
arrogance of just like the you know yeah
with we felt it we've done those shows
and we've done those audiences and
they're the worst [__] crowds ever
and then guess what I was in Madison
Wisconsin all weekend and they were
[__] electric yep they were great so
it's like you go to regular people
they're great you go to these people all
these people who are like artists and
supposed to get get it yep you're the
hardest [__] Crowd Oh yeah yeah
exactly cool the holdovers got a lot of
stuff Giamatti and uh what's her name
again Divine something she's so good in
the movie so cool that they both and I
saw Giamatti afterwards at the with the
Golden Globe kind of like ins sideways
right yeah yeah you got that great
bottle of wine with a plastic cup yeah
that was perfect good good point just
one of the best movies oh pain you got
to love pain pain is incredible yeah I
like this movie people people you know I
really like Joe L hated it I I thought
it was great you look it's that's what
movies are right it's like a movie like
this type of like kind of sweet movie
it's like it's some people are going to
find it cheesy I guess but I it it got
me I loved it yeah it's supposed to be a
little cheesy what about um yeah a lot
of good stuff won Jesus big
uh man those are Golden
Globes holy hell what else uh what else
one well oh I didn't see oh dude I saw
Ramy give a big smooch in the mouth to
saw that on Twitter Ry and uh and Mark
Ruffalo big kiss on the mouth oh how
about that all right world that movie
one I haven't seen it but our boy Simon
Rex told me it's kids killer the one
with Emma Stone oh yeah what's up with
stone and uh Taylor Swift are beefing I
thought it was a joke oh is that a joke
I think it's a joke this is just turning
into TMZ over here yeah what are we
doing Mark rufalo is in the
news
extra
oh yeah look at that oh get some that's
uh my my lady Mark Ruffalo is like her
her number one I feel like that's every
lady doesn't every lady love Ruffalo but
I I'll take he's so non it's funny he's
the Hulk cuz he's so non-threatening I
know and the Hulk and then every
interview like oh God uh we need to help
poor people got to really just you know
do our part he's a chubby guy with curly
hair so I'm like great I'm I'm glad her
fantasy's Nota well he's like a he's a
port I don't know portly or flabby we'll
go flabby I heard a rumor in like
2017 that he was going to play
Columbo that's perfect and I lost it I
was like this is perfect well he's he's
in zodiac remember he's like amazing
that came from he's wearing the jacket
and everything oh yeah 70s Columbo
Columbo could use a a revamp Columbo is
awesome Columbo it's weird cuz every
episode's an hour 30 right so it's like
is that right yeah it's crazy and it's
like I think it was a 2our show
with commercials yeah with commercials
dude some of those apps I'm like they're
great but we could snip so much of this
out oh yeah like the person deciding to
do the murder it's like oh it's like
Columbo taking his dog to the vet it's
like what are we doing here that's a
good app I've seen that that's that's
the one with cassavetes right yeah
that's right oh my God F I've seen my
Columbo we got a lot of range over here
we got Ramy and Columbo in the same
10minute podcast cetes oh yeah what was
his thing he's in five Oscar winners and
then he's out no that's John cazelle oh
sorry C is the director got it got it
you were telling me some we were hanging
last night me and uh Salam Mona and he
was telling me some uh what were you
saying last night oh it was about um
Phil Hoff they had it written into his
will he said if I should decease uh I
give my money willingly to my ex-wife or
whoever it was but my son has to be
raised in New York City O that's in the
will interesting I love it I know you
love it too I love it I [__] love
that I wonder why said that cuz it's
culture we got culture here I guess so
we also got a lot of problems but you I
I got one for you uh this is this is
like a this happened on the way here I
was uh I was on the train and a guy
starts clearly a crazy guy starts Shadow
Boxing on the train here we go I it's
like I know it's a ticking Time Bomb so
I I get up on the next stop and I go to
the next car and then like one more stop
the train cleared out and I was like I
saw that one coming oh wow I I was proud
I [__] called that he was yeah he
went nuts I guess but yeah I can't drive
but I can tell well that's I got New
York Instinct baby that's New York it
turns you into this like uh quick fast
food psychologist you're like that guy's
bipolar he's schizophrenic you're like
uh reading people's minds in two seconds
not only that but it's like you know
technology has also turned us like we
get irritated by [__] so much more
quickly like I used to be like much more
alert now I'm like [__] I got to pause
an audio book to like see if this guy's
crazy yeah so true yeah the crazies are
out I saw a couple today saw one
yesterday yeah they're back on the
train New York Magazine did uh a really
in-depth story about Jordan Neely that
guy oh the Michael Jackson guy Michael
Jackson guy who was sorry I pulled up
the eBay thing uh he was killed in the
subway the choke cold yes that's right
damn yeah what the hell you bringing
that up for he just said crazy homeless
guy in the subway oh okay yeah all right
don't stop to you good enough oh [__]
that's horrible yeah no that's uh that's
a great cover for a guy just got
murdered on the train you have a great
photo of the guy sure is that like CCTV
footage I don't know I think that's like
a classic like that's like a perfect
story for America right now because you
get the far the farle being like we need
to help these people in the far right
like he's a menace you know y everyone
is angry and but then like really it's
you know there's Nuance to everything
Nuance yeah well like the Cat Williams
interview you know what do you think of
that well I listen to the whole thing I
I I never listen to podcast that long I
love cat I think he's one of the
funniest guys on the planet I want him
on here oh I'd love to get cat on cat we
want you've made we need like a chart of
people to check off yeah yeah CO's out
cats
in but uh cat he's so funny you also
want to be on his good side like let's
have him on so he doesn't hate us you
know because you don't want him [__] on
us in 5 years but so funny I do think a
lot of it I listen to the whole thing
and some of you're like well this isn't
true that's not real what what's not
true well he said he had 10 kids he has
eight then he said he reads 3,000
rounding up he has three he reads 3,000
books a year you're like well that's
kind of impossible you know and he had a
couple 3,000 a year I don't even
remember that dude pull up by the way
Shannon sharp one of the worst
interviewers I've ever heard and like
look he was a amazing football player
Hall of Fame tight end beat the Giants
piece of [__] but uh God here's what I
love YouTube I wonder if there's a
compilation Shannon laugh okay he's got
the most girlish laugh I've ever heard
he's this hulking [__] I mean I don't
know if you've seen this guy shirtless
he's still shredded oh yeah he's huge
and his laugh is
like little Michael Jackson or Michael
Tyson here we
go oh yeah what the [__] is that that's
that's kind of nice that does not match
the uh that sounds like a Bridge Troll
he's like how many you got to pass the
riddle to get through the
bridge
oh man
sorry yeah that that got 30 million
views it's [__] funny that laugh no
he I mean if it was him doing a straight
up interview I couldn't have handled it
but luckily catch steam rolls him and
just takes over totally but I mean I
love how he just kept making it about
like sports he'd be like youever been
booed he's like you ever dropped the
pass like everything they're not the
same dropping to pass happens he's so
good well Nathan Macintosh made the
great point he's like that pod was so
big that we forgot about the Epstein
list for a second that's how big it was
I think the Epstein list was
anticlimactic because we knew most of
the names already yeah they keep saying
more is coming I I don't know it's it's
I heard Bruce Willis but he says he
doesn't remember so how can you do
better than stepen Hawking on the
[__] list I know I know that's gold
but you know he's he's a phander he was
always kind of uh stepping out or
rolling out but uh he's a hornball man
that's a sticky keyboard horny dude yeah
it's kind of motivational it he
accomplished more in his life yeah oh
yeah than most people I mean I was going
to say able-bodied people but yeah he's
an astrophysicist yeah I mean he he did
a lot oh yeah he's solving for the
equation of cream pie all right I'll see
you all in Hell there you go but uh he
can't drive but he's all right with
trafficking
okay video to
come I heard someone say he uh he likes
to watch and was like that's all he can
do this isn't my joke where someone was
like he's investigating black holes hey
that's good I got needs special needs
all
right okay we're having
fun any word from our guest okay just
checking well uh what should we drink
today by the way oh yeah I can make
something do we have ice TR some I could
scoop some ice up you also just maybe do
a scotch or something do a neat new NE
maybe a bodega we could [__] with some
some of that Offerman special o he won
our boy Nick Offerman oh yeah shout out
to our former uh great episode with our
our boy Nick Offerman what he win the
last of us he won for the Last of Us oh
really that was a killer rep he was
awesome he and so was him on ours yeah
yeah but yeah him him on that show was
like pretty incredible that was huge
yeah he crushed it man and the other guy
I forgot his name but he's also
incredible yeah jvas won as well so it
was like a big it was like a felt like a
a real year it wasn't like well they're
checking boxers or what's who is this
really that good why'd he win why'd she
win this felt like real real good picks
well succession everyone Buck Kendall
won and there was the GIF of of the last
shot of Kendall looking sad on the on
the bench oh man the internet really is
unbeaten un unbeaten and uh yeah
succession ruled that was such a good
show oh yeah
as Joe says billions succession for
retards the billions is good man I never
got it I never watched it I should check
it out first few seasons are killer okay
I love Giamatti and I like cman and I'm
in it and you're in it for an episode
and soda soda's great is it I got to
check it out all right looks like he's
going to get the guests what what else
is going on what did did you pull some
stuff up can we can we pause for a sec
cuz I want to piss anyway I'm dying a
piss okay let's just all right we might
be drunk is brought to you by diet smoke
if you're looking to get in the shrooms
diet smoke is the place to start you
probably know diet smoke as the Premier
Source for THC products but they've also
just launched their brand new mushroom
gummies which is the perfect intro to
shrooms wow this is nice to know they
have a huge range of strengths and doses
so you can choose your own adventure I
love shrooms I'm a big fan and you never
know what you're taking a cap a stem who
knows it's all over the road so get get
this this is the way to do it diet smoke
not sure what what to buy they got a
top-notch customer service team that's
committed to guiding you towards the
right products for you and your body
whether you're looking for something
strong to unwind a boost of energy to
keep you going or a lighter more mellow
High diet smoke has what you need join
the diet smoke community and discover
the Buzz for you visit diet smoke.com
today and use drunk code drunk for 50%
off any item and enjoy your journey to
Bliss that's diet.com and use code drunk
for 50% off any item diet smoke your
partner in finding the perfect THC and
mushroom products hey we're back Sam
smelling the lemon juice he's making us
a cocktail think we're having a paper
plane does this smell like weed this
smells smells like weed smell weed are
you supposed to I think you're supposed
to refrigerate lemon juice once it's
open nah give that a goog Sally after
open ah it's right on the goddamn label
well our guest here is Chad Daniels
everybody am I recording right now my
good yeah you're on with that one of our
favorite Comics he's got a YouTube
special out and it's uh you hit both
sides which I love oh thanks yeah
everybody's picking a side and going all
in you hit both yeah I'm just right in
the middle same we need that you know
the enough's enough already it's like
right how you how did you divy up which
material to do on did you just had two
hours locked and loaded and you're like
I'm you wanted to do it this way this
was the plan yeah well what so I knew I
was going to pay for the camera crew and
pay for everybody so I was like why not
just get both of them out for less money
so really was the cheap the cheap route
and that's why I did it this point did
you change outfits at least I did I
changed the set I changed outfits and
then just did uh two different hours
beautiful damn that's great that's so
funny was just for the money to do
though too it was a little weird I mean
it was do you remember the scene from um
oh what's that uh old school where will
frell is like on the debate team yes and
then he does that big thing about
Finance or whatever and then he goes oh
my God I blacked out I don't know what
happened that's how I felt when I walked
off stage the second time cuz I didn't
do any pickups right we didn't edit it
it was just that was it wow oh yeah with
James Carville yeah that was such a fun
movie for us to well articulated this is
Chad doing his
closer there you go well that must be
nice because shooting a special is such
a ordeal and it's a mind [__] and it's
exhausting so then you got it all out in
one day and you're done yeah two of them
then and then just moved on that's great
it it it was fun it did feel good and um
I'm going to shoot another one March 2nd
and then I'm done shooting for a while
Jesus CHR you shooting three in one year
so I did it December 1st or December 3rd
so it would
be uh yeah I guess three in 14 months
that's [__] crazy who are you
Chappelle I mean I'm telling you like
you know there's there's a little if if
I would have done if I could have picked
it right um Netflix bought the second
one that I did in Madison hey con so
thank you but if I if I could have
picked I would have just gone rapid fire
on these things um but you know I slowed
it down and told some stories and stuff
like that but we'll see how it goes all
right great well I watched the the
YouTube one and I loved it oh thank you
very much yeah check it out I mean
you've always been prolific you've
always like you know I remember like you
were one of the early Comics to uh kind
of catch some heat with Pandora and like
I feel like I learned about Pandora
because we had the same agent and she
was like Chad [__] on Pandora dude
yeah I didn't even know I got on stage
once in Spokane Washington and this guy
yelled out do IHOP and then everyone
started cheering and I go how do you
guys know what IHOP is and they're like
Pandora idiot there's I didn't even know
there's comedy on Pandora at that point
wow so I didn't know anything you were
number one on there for a while yeah for
a little bit that's not bad yeah you're
in people's homes in their cars yeah and
then you got that lawsuit what happened
the royalty lawsuit where
trying trying to squeeze a little more
and they took a bunch of stuff down so I
got some I got some dough out of that
did you a little bit did you good no cuz
I I bailed on it and I said I'd rather
go back on Pandora well my problem was
Comedy Central [__] me like they were
just withholding all these royalties for
like years they just I was like I don't
ever get those royalty checks and uh man
it's crazy yeah when you get it in a
lump sum it's a nice little nice little
how you do yeah oh yeah yeah I mean I
get that monthly serious money and
that's a nice little finger in the butt
cuz you're like oo I didn't see that
coming absolutely felt damn good yeah
you just get that email and then you
click Artist summary and you're like
well what is this about a new pair of
sneakers we're getting a steak dinner
what is this going to
Sizzler yeah but yeah boy you're
cranking it out so now you got to build
a new new set yeah I'll just do that but
that's going to be Hometown stuff St
Paul I'm doing that be uh oh it's on my
uh we got a woman do this one going to
be on YouTube as well or is this going
are you selling this one too so I'm not
sure about the one on March 2nd I'm
going to I'm going to do what I did I'm
going to do it myself produce it myself
and then try to sell it after that yeah
I got to say we did the fully loaded
with Berke for a couple dates yeah that
was fun so fun but Bert I got to watch
Bert watch you and his wife you know
Leanne is just like oh my God we're all
dying in the back cuz you were doing the
the right vers left closer and it was
[__] epic in an arena it was killing
oh thanks that Oklahoma City was a fun
night I rode out on that horse and being
an idiot might not work this drink might
not work I don't think we have enough
lemon so what I'm fine with the old
lemon juice it can't be that tainted
huh we'll see if this works see how it
goes this doesn't look like it's going
to work that's fresh right there let me
smell this s bag lemon juice around it's
[__]
bad M that's not
great you're not Kidd I've eaten some
Sour snatch in my day and that is oh
that is rough you're supposed to ref so
close to this drink working it might
still work yeah look at you you're like
a mad scientist over there sure
sometimes you get a drink and you're
like God there's too much lemon in
this offset the sweet though oh God we
we'll see we'll fake it this sucks I
apologize all right going to get more
more lemon with lime
nah man this is like bottom of the
barrel for us we need beard you man yeah
I guess we got to call him back we had
our own bartender oh hell yeah yeah but
he's not here today obviously but we'll
get him back so where you staying in the
city you doing some spots no I don't
normally do spots but I did one last
night I did uh bonfire oh yeah and then
Bobby Kelly I was heading down to the uh
the seller and he goes well hop on this
show I'm doing so I just did one random
and then I hung out and just talked up
at the in the lounge area oh great yeah
it was nice I got to tell you I took uh
11 days off because of New Year's and
Christmas and all that for me that's an
eternity I don't know how you feel cuz
you're up in Fergus Falls you know to
Minneapolis oh you did Kelsey and I
moved to the big city you
guys I can see how was that how was that
change for you uh it's just 2 and a half
hours closer to the airport Jesus [__]
did you do the road before that I mean I
had kids so it was like kids are first
then comedy then other stuff and uh and
so you just got to make sure you're home
yeah but uh you know I still got to it
was weird cuz I I get to raise my kids
how I want to raise them but then also
still do comedy which is totally my
favorite thing so mhm how do you want to
raise him well yeah well done got it yes
cook him all the way
through yeah well you I always talk
about you like you're this Commando
living in the woods and when there's a
show we're like call Chad you're like I
told you I quit and then they're like we
need you though you're the only guy with
the uh the special tools and then you
kind of come out of retirement and come
do some show hope this does suck by the
way I'm sure it'll be great well cheers
it up here boys hell yeah it looks like
the right color paper plane yeah cheers
paper plane all
right not Alaskan the door is still on
this one still pretty good that's very
good yeah what do you got going here hey
that's great pull up that Alaska flight
you got to see this the door flies off
in mid a uh it's Amaro Nino apparo
Bodega cat whiskey or whiskey and uh and
lemon lemon juice in equal parts I
didn't know the first two things you
said yeah don't get too fancy amaru is
like you have like a you can just drink
that and eat it's pretty good okay Amaro
stmy sounds like a basketball Maro Nino
he's on the the Bulls this year all
right there you go look at this have you
seen this yet Alaska Air their flights
are looking pretty cheap right now and
I'm looking at them I'm kind of like
it's not going to happen again and the
odds are great and
getting a better idea of what exactly
caused the window of an oh was it a
window sorry I thought it was a door and
was
modified emergency the plane excuse me
didn't have as many emergency exits had
fewer passenger seats so the window that
flew off was actually a door that
covered
what that kid shirt flew right out of
there they said damn like right off his
body no no it just had like a sweatshirt
on the seat and it went oh I'm sure yeah
and that must [__] hurt your ears too
that's got to scare the [__] out of you
oh my God I
know holy hell we fly more than
anyone oh they got the they got the uh
the mask coming down I just flew from
Portland on Alaska actually no way yeah
maybe was La this is wild I mean people
have to be going nuts right oh I'm
surprised there's no
screaming damn their stock must be
through the
floor yeah yeah I would think so so two
people arrived late didn't get on the
flight and those were those two seats
they empty seats that's crazy they were
empty seats cuz that would have probably
I mean remember that uh what was it Sun
Country I don't want to say but cuz I'm
not sure but it was a some you know
b-level Airline and the the window came
out and somebody got sucked into it and
it like it killed them because it pulled
all their blood like into their ass or
something what yeah it was really
strange damn that's like a Homer Simpson
moment you know like sucked right in the
hole holy
[__] well that's where you need the fat
guy taking the two seats you know cuz
then only one person dies is that a real
law or is that a joke I heard that fat
people on Southwest was it get get a
free
seat free seat or they have to buy two
they don't have to pay for it by law but
then but our argument was like all right
what if you're tall tall is no good cuz
you're still compact you're just long
but you're born tall I I think the fat
thing is crazy I think it's unfair to
the to the thin
folk I think it yeah that's a bit much
yeah you got fat that's not on us it's
not on the airline now they're losing
money for a seat cuz you ate a waffle
other airlines is what they say to you
you got fat dude sorry you're [__]
gross well my thing with the F we've
covered this before I was a fat kid I
got fat families that was chubby as hell
that goddamn McDonald's Monopoly game it
got me oh that was like a Ponzi scheme
for fat kids cuz I thought I was going
to get Boardwalk yeah board there was
there was no [__] Boardwalk no one
got that it was a scam there it is is
praise for customers of size policy
Southwest there you go but my thing is
if you're fat that's fine you can do
whatever you want to your body but when
you're spilling into my seat now it's
secondhand fat cuz now it's affecting me
absolutely thank you and it's not like a
good feeling it's hot it's like a like a
moist kind of a yes yes it's not great
the only time it is good is when you can
actually nuzzle into it sure you you
forgot the neck pillow and you once they
hit a job with the Hut level of fat you
get to yeah speaking of it's a bean bag
might be a good segue Sam asked me to
pull this up earlier oh this disgusts me
I get so mad I send this to S we send
each other videos like this but this one
just makes me angry this McDonald's one
okay we got a burger nugget fries
wrapped into a burrito oh wow this is
why the terrorist hate us I mean this is
disgusting oh that's fun but here's the
thing I get it I get people would hate
us but then just kill him right you know
what I mean I think he's got that
covered don't come for yeah don't come
for all of us that's I completely agree
person
yeah yeah there's not enough garbage in
there Jesus Christ to me it's like I
understand the making like people want
to recreate stuff on these things so
they'll do like the Taco Bell thing
where you put the you know you wrap it
up you put the tortilla in there for the
crunch the Gordita Crunch thing you want
to remake oh the Crunch Wrap Supreme but
that's an actual thing yes this you're
just throwing garbage you may as well
just dump it in a [__] Hefty bag and
then just chug it you know I got to tell
you I probably would do that one time
just to say I did it well KFC did it for
a minute remember when they did the bowl
I got that bowl I was let me try bread
it was like meat meat and meat or
something potato a bunch of potatoes and
gravy was the Killer and cheese yeah no
I felt horrible after it it was a huge
mistake well Pat and Oswalt had the
whole thing the sadness pile and a
failure bowl that
which is so poetic that was his old
thing on that and then the double down
don't forget about the double down
that's what I was thinking what was that
that was a a chicken breast chicken
breast meat like Patty between it with
cheese so the the bun was the
breast I had a uh a double cheeseburger
eating contest at McDonald's once and
got five of them wow that's like an
Apocalypse Now with the slow
fan you get the meat sweats even like if
you eat too much meat I I've gotten a
few times where I'm like I just wake up
covered in sweat and I'm like oh [__]
that's meat yeah you're not supposed to
eat that much of it I know I get that
too after barbecue there's been times in
my life I'll wake up sweaty no meat just
because of other bad decisions right I
mean just anything sure yeah the booze
sweats that's no joke where you sweat
and you're like I smell like Jin yes
literally and it's all coming out at
once yes barbecue when you break it down
is just like Smoked Meats with sugar
that's it it's the worst [__] you can
like pre-show you're eating smoking is
bad for you sugar is bad for you meat is
bad for you and then you're like why am
I so [__] lethargic yeah not this is
poison I'm putting it it tastes great
it's great poison you get two sides with
that that plate so now you're getting
mac and cheese so now you're getting a
carb with the cheese and you get mac and
cheese mac and cheese I and I try to get
a collared green which is my way make
you feel better about it you you get the
collar green you're like this is healthy
or drench in [__] meat sauce yeah you
put the sauce on that too of course and
the Mac I like I like a good like I mean
it's you're asking for poison but you
get like a good Bean thing on the side
sometimes yeah PTO or something there's
a whole thing called fat influencers
online where people just you watch them
eat like that video we just saw and this
lady put a compilation together of some
of these fat influencers uhoh just
because I'm fat that doesn't invalidate
the things that I say she died oh you
ready to get super siiz she died too
today I've got the big Fruit Loop
he's
dead on my fat positive radio show which
didn't last long because she died oh my
I don't like I don't like like I don't
like how much joy she seems to be having
with this though yeah I don't like that
she's like gloating a little right like
yeah it's [__] insane that they're
doing this but also like you know this
isn't like world class reporting yeah
sure she's just yelling to her younger
sister bring me another
one I used to watch my 600 lb life at
Arty Lang's house and it was
probably the hardest I've ever laughed
is just him he would just like
commentate on it he would just like he
would just like be riffing about how
dumb these people
are and I [__] miss Ry Lang dude oh
he's the man but that TLC has really
become the modern day freak Show you
know it's like the fattest people on
earth midgets uh it just goes on and on
like I have 12 kids or whatever it's
just a freak Show but on TV is that the
Russian wife show yes that too that one
yeah yeah it's all TLC look at look
that's my 400 lb life he's not far off
those 200 pounds make a big difference
though that's true those last 200 will
get you man he was funny we're talking
about like still alive yeah what are we
doing here yeah I just haven't seen him
in a while I was just wondering like
what did I miss no no no he's so [__]
I remember Joe Macky and I went on his
show Once like years like probably maybe
12 years ago whenever we had that Direct
TV show oh yeah I went on that and uh
and we went on and Mackie goes I I
already uh I already Mom twice tonight
and and Ry goes here and where else
oh man so quick he's the only guy I've
seen get a tell dying it tells like
rolled over laughing at already Lang oh
nice yeah yeah he was he was like radio
gold cuz he was a great Storyteller but
he was just so freaking quick as well I
know all right I feel like you left AR
you garbage you came here we've talked
about the double down the sadness Bowl
fat people I'm like all right we got to
we got to steer away from
garbage how about those Nicks I'm
[__] loving it he I'm rocking in New
York Knicks yeah I haven't watched the
Knicks since uh like Patrick Ying used
to make excuses about his fingers before
playoff games just in case he did poorly
right right and then he would Dominate
and he'd be like yeah I did that with a
bad finger I loved it it it taught me
how to do a pre- excuse right and I've
used it my whole life free excuse is
good yeah I like that I'm use that with
the wife buten trouble getting it up
lately have you really no I'm saying pre
that was in college you go well I
haven't done this in a while so might be
fast and then it isn't and you're like
well Patrick Ewing
did you go up on stage with some notes
you're like let me try some new [__] out
it's just your hour you been torn with
all your Clos [__] around let me [__]
around I've never done the Patrick Ewing
figure but when I ate a girl out once
she gave me the
Matumbo whatever happened to him he's
around I got him do a cameo for one of
my specials yes oh really I got him pull
it up somewhere it's great he crushed it
I just gave him a script to read and he
basically just nailed it uh yeah just
looks samel d m Matumbo but uh he's got
his own coffee he's a humanitarian wow
he's uh he I got his autograph when I
was a kid after I just would wait
outside and I had a blue warm-up on me
and I handed him a black Sharpie to
autograph it and and he did this and he
takes out his own pen it was blue so he
just signed Blue on Blue so it just
didn't show up he thought he was doing
like something cool I was like thanks oh
damn all I is this autograph fail is
that it no no that's not it it's it's on
my Instagram oh okay it's it's probably
from a long time ago you're a sports guy
football yep Vikings
yes there you go yes unfortunately is it
true that Bill Murray owns a baseball
team called the twins a minor league I
think he it's the St Paul Saints and I
think he used to own them maybe he got
out of it now oh okay but he used to
frequent that place and people love it
man I would love to bump into him some
of the stories I hear where he grabs the
french fries and he just goes no one's
ever going to believe you like that kind
of [__] is wild and I I love when people
use their celebrity for that I I
completely agree I've heard of him
showing up at frat parties with like a
case of beer and like Austin Texas was
like pretend I wonder I wonder if it's
ever not work
I wonder if people they just don't know
he is are just like no [__] you old guy
I don't can you imagine rejecting Bill
Murray I know well he's a weird looking
guy he's old as [__] now and I think
some some gen Zer would probably be like
who's this creep I mean like he we love
Bill Murray but I mean he he really got
away with being like a cool dick that
was like you rewatch like Groundhog's
Day he's just a [__] but you but
he's so charismatic Scrooged yeah the
same thing quick what quick change quick
change that's a good one it's hard to
pull off the cool likable dick now
because uh it's all about like being
positive and nice and all that yeah now
if you're a dick everyone's like this
person this is why they're a dick this
is when it started with tweeting yeah
they do a flashback the mom's beating
them yeah but even Jimmy Fallon they're
like that guy who worked from was like
he's so mean you're like come on he's
your boss what do we do it here also
that guy's mean I don't believe it I
don't think so either yeah I mean how
were you raised that's like met him I
mean he's like he's a cool dude very
cool guy what what were you say I was
going to say I I started doing comedy at
Acme Comedy Company and it's spoil city
right the open mic is 300 standing room
only great Club everybody's loud and
then you get out and you go do a bar
show and you're like oh my God this yes
this is what comedy actually is so you
feel like what kind of parenting what
kind of upbringing did you have if
Fallon's a dick exactly ex I mean you're
just so spoiled and out of touch I do
think a lot of it's like people just get
so much like they're searching for so
much positive reinforcement now that
maybe like that's what social media is
everyone's on their phone everything's
for them so if your boss isn't like
kissing your ass now I feel like they're
just like wait why aren't you why are
you doing more for me yeah I hate to
breaking news you guys but um words of
affirmation isn't everyone's love
language so [__] sack up dude yes
you're working on 30 Rock on the
tonight's show I'll tell that's a pee by
the way is just people's love language
it's like that's my love language I'm
like well I don't like that you like my
girlfriend would do that she'll be like
well buying you stuff is is uh my love
language I'm like well stop buying me
[__] I live in a cramped apartment in
New York City right you got me she got
me like eight sweatshirts and I was like
what is this [__] Jesus it's like a nice
it's nice but it's like now I have to
like go return this [__] and it's tough
It's a tough thing to complain about too
like I know it's gifts so I'm like but
I'm like it is annoying and they're
saying it's their love language which is
you're then you're
rejecting but come up with your it's not
like my love language is $100 bills and
[__] does work there's like five
cemented in love languag you have to
pick between My love language get my ass
eaten you
know I've actually said that to it it's
like I do that's what I prefer receiving
yes yeah yeah that love language [__]
caught on real quick and I I don't like
it well it's another thing it's like
well it's about you exactly it's not
it's not about uh the person you're
supposed L loving yes yes yeah like I
know this guy he's very funny comic and
he's like my girlfriend's love language
is words of affirmation giving them but
I get so uncomfortable when people give
me compliments so it hurt you know she's
like this is my love language and he's
just shrinking in the kitchen because he
can't handle it all he can't handle the
those words of affirmation he's like
leave me alone just tell me I'm nice
once in the morning and then stop please
well we need a hate language if we're
gonna have a love language you we need
the opposite to to say like I don't want
this I think that's just Twitter yeah I
guess so I guess so but it's like if
you're giving me your love thing I also
should be able to say all right well I
don't like this some I don't like this
thing just cuz you should be able to
turn it down yeah it's like getting hit
on in a bar right hey I'd like to take
you home no thank you and then all of a
sudden it's your love language so I have
to accept it exactly doesn't work that
my love language is sexual assault you
really I'm feeling rejected right now
there you go my love language is not not
accepting other Love
Languages ever that's pretty good that
could be something that could be a bit
did do you have any peeves cuz I got one
let's hear it well I um I I don't know
if you've ever come across this but the
guy who's trying
to think of what you're going to say
before you finish saying it but he's all
wrong oh so so he interrupts you yes
annoying mad lips yes exactly exactly
and I can see him like he's like
mouthing it and getting all excited I'm
like no no let me just say it and then
we'll go from there stop trying to
figure it out as I'm saying I guess he's
kind of bored with me talking or
something he need spoilers with every TV
show to that guy yeah right no spoilers
just let me finish that's a weird when
people who like I was talking my mom and
she was like well what happens in the
movie I was like why don't want to tell
you if you're going to see it she's like
no I like spoilers I'm like that's weird
to me I've never heard anyone say that
some people like spoilers wow I was in h
Columbia Missouri one time first of all
let me let me back up Deja Vu yeah but
my my girlfriend is going to be watching
this and so when you brought up someone
trying to finish your sentences wait
your girlfriend watches your podcast I'm
sure really yeah and I know for a fact
that she is probably right now vibrating
a little bit going like aren't you going
to tell them you interrupt me all the
time so I would like to tell you
sometimes so she she's one of these
people that and and I love it she thinks
about what she's going to say before she
says it okay I am a [__] you oops sorry
five minutes later I don't think about
anything I just go in and she thinks
about it so while she's thinking about
it I'm I I'm getting like ansy so I'll
try to guess what she's going to do and
she's like just [__] let me let me
collect my but that's different I think
what you're saying is different than
what he's saying I think Mark is like
telling a story and the person keeps
guessing I think you're describing
someone being like uh that's different
yeah so so what you're saying is they're
trying to if if you were watching a
comic it's like trying to guess the
punchline yeah okay okay I it's
different I think she's not getting to
the thing whereas mark is telling the
story and you're just being interrupted
right yeah pretty much sure well yeah it
feels like interrupting but I I I do see
the difference I uh so okay Columbia
Missouri Deja Vu I get heckled by this
lady say some pretty nasty [__] to her
she's screaming at me I go listen I
don't have much time left let's meet at
the bar whatever if you want to talk
about it her husband's there and uh and
they leave and they're pissed off and
they call the the owner he's mad at me
yep I go to um the life of David Gil
it's called oh yeah that movie Kevin spy
Kevin spy and uh like 50 twists and
turns in this thing good movie and I'm
walking out and I hear there's the
comedian now you hear that tone and you
go keep walking but not me right my ego
goes that must be me I turn it's this
lady and her husband and she's like uh
what movie did you go see and I went
life of David Gail and she goes uh well
he's probably funnier than you and I was
like okay and I go what movie you going
to to see and she said same movie and
then I told them both what happened and
I I don't I don't think they wanted the
spoiler but uh man I mean just to get it
be great if you ran back into them two
years later for K
packs just every Spacey movie and then
you really spoil where you're like he's
going to touch some
kids wow he's acquitted though that's
true I shouldn't say that yeah he got
off all right um but you're right he was
cleared of all charges you say it like
that uh that's hilarious you did that
that was I remember that club that
[__] stunk that that weekend was
rough I you know I actually liked it for
the most part there was a dance club
downstairs yeah that wasn't my favorite
part I was so I was married kids so I
went up in the DJ booth with this guy Q
he was like the DJ for the night and I
would always just watch CU I never want
to go down and dance and never want to
like get in trouble or whatever but i'
I'd sit up and watch and that was kind
of fun just watching the all the college
kids do that stuff but uh yeah it it
could be tough first time I ever worked
at Cat Williams whoa you work with
Williams I was supposed to so Kevin Hart
had that weekend okay and then they had
the same management or something and or
maybe agent but Kevin Hart had something
to do Cat Williams comes in and uh and
you know they called me they like hey do
you want to work with Kevin har I'm like
yeah and then they go he canceled then
I'm going to cancel and they go nah you
might like this guy so I go fur coat so
I get off stage full fur coat Head to
Toes cowboy boots giant belt buckle like
as big as a dinner plate and then he had
two gorgeous like 6'2 blondes wow walk
him up to Stage What in in the middle of
Missouri wow which was great and then he
[__] murdered so hard he's the I
think he's probably the
only one of the only Headliners I've
ever worked with that I watched every
single second of every single show wow
was it like a co- headliner you opened I
guess I opened for yeah cuz I thought I
was going to be opening for Kevin Hart
and I knew he had all this success I'm
like yeah I'll come down and open for
that of course sure and there's a Deja
Vu it was a Deja Vu yeah wow was it a
black crowd no interesting it was so it
was still Thursday night was college
night and then it was like half College
half townies Friday and Saturday and
dude he destroyed and I he had a cowboy
hat it was it was insane but it was so
so fun to watch I remember having one
really good set there and I remember one
really bad one I remember like and Greg
Warren hooked me up with uh missou
tickets sure oh nice yeah went to the
football game but uh yeah man Cat
Williams uh was he cool was he nice very
cool very nice guy did he watch any of
your stuff yep very complimentary but
you never know like if that's just you
know [__] I don't know dude he
doesn't seem like to type the sugar coat
yeah well I don't know I mean this is a
long time ago obviously he was working
at club and he was filling in for
somebody so it's clearly it isn't that
crazy cat Williams is doing a fill in
weekend yeah wow this is like a freaking
Arena act well you what was that
88 I don't know it had have been uh man
maybe early 2000s damn that's incredible
that was outrageous though to to watch
him walk up in a cowboy hat Boots the
fur coat everything and then have the
models bring him up yes it was just
outrageous to watch every what a weird
expense I know you know to be like I'm
going to this is when I'm going to drop
my money on you see what people like
they have built in for their deal but
he's a showman Rider is like nuts and
fruit he's like I need two [__]
models I need two Scandinavian or they
have to do right is he like that in the
green room is he still Cat Williams e in
the green room or is he kind of shut
down a little not really shut down but I
mean just still very very cool very
funny wow but you seem like the type of
guy he would like cuz you're kind of
like you know we all were like the three
of us we all kind of like Club
Journeymen you know and I think he
seemed at least from that interview to
like that yeah that wasn't his problem
he liked people that paid their dues yes
you know the way he talked about uh
being like a journeyman the clubs and
the people he liked and what he really
didn't like just makes me think about
like movies like bull durm where you're
like this dude is a [__] lifer in the
minor leagues he went up to the show for
like 21 days like there's something
beautiful about like just being a lifer
in the minor leagues cuz you just
[__] love it you're not you're like
when we all started like there wasn't
this type of success for for stand-ups
there wasn't like this booming upper
middle class it was kind of like you
were like Jim Carrey or you were like a
[__] bottom of the road headliner you
know so it is cool that there's we are
in a boom right now oh yeah absolutely
there are more Arena acts now than ever
before it's insane it's like peers I
know I know and then all our friends who
have like millions and millions of
dollars and uh big houses it's wacky
yeah it's pretty interesting cuz we just
got into this like maybe I won't have a
a day job maybe I'll get a movie one day
you know and now it's like hey maybe I
could be seora you know maybe I could
fly private one day who knows when I
started I was like I just don't want to
have a boss yeah that's it and now you
get you know a bunch of [__] that goes
with it too it's outrageous what are
your like what's your clubs like you do
clubs you doing theaters right now what
are you doing I do mostly clubs I mean
like 98% clubs yeah what are your rooms
do you like your favorite markets right
now cities markets I sound like a
[__]
kill me what are your favorite I mean I
I like every I'm doing Tempe coming up I
really like that place I like it was
interesting I did one time I did the
Tempe Improv one night and then I did
standup live the next night 15minute
drive completely different responses to
the exact same jokes isn't that
fascinating I just didn't I didn't know
if it was because it was on the campus
Tempe or something but it was outrageous
you like Tempe better I ate [__] at
stand up I I maybe not ate [__] but it
wasn't good I like doing that I like in
that room stand up live yeah yeah I like
them both I've never done Tempe but I've
done stand up live a few times and it's
always it's always solid I mean Phoenix
as a whole is a great Market yeah really
good but I was just really surprised
that that 15minute drive yeah did it
isn't that weird I mean sometimes I'm I
was I was the seller two nights ago I
did uh I did a joke a new joke
downstairs uh in the village underground
[__] killed then I go upstairs for
new jokes to try it again each [__] I'm
like literally I went upstairs yeah
there floorboards between that those two
jokes but yeah isn't that weird I mean
like you just don't know there's a time
in Milwaukee at this old uh old Club
Milwaukee Cafe yeah been there baby I
was doing this joke Late Show crickets
and I was so [__] mad that they just
weren't giving anything that I record
all my sets on my phone and so I pulled
up the set from before and I found that
joke and I go here's what's supposed to
happen and I put it on the mic I'm like
how is this different that's exactly how
I told them how did they re you lazy
pieces of
[__] well that's why comedy is so
frustrating cuz you shoot a basketball
it goes in that's two points but you
shoot a basketball at comedy Cafe at the
late show and I don't get the two points
it doesn't make sense well that was the
thing that cat kept saying in the
interview where he was like saying this
is a sport I'm like no it's not that was
one part where I'm like this is not a
sport this is a night fight this is
entertainment this is sport is like
clear and cut facts he's the winner he's
the loser this is things changeing
comedy crowds change it's that's not I
mean I think he approaches it like a
sport clearly like the amount of hours
he does the amount of touring he does
and I and I get that but it's just uh
yeah I don't I don't I to me this is not
we're not athletes you do have to take
care of yourself with all the traveling
we do like it's more of guys who have a
drinking podcast sure yeah it's more of
a blue collar job I think cuz you got to
just go up go up like the joke worked
there then it didn't work at the next
spot your place downstairs upstairs
totally different response that's why
you got to keep running it running it
running it running it just to get a
baseline of like it's almost like a
median how does this joke do CU it's not
going to work everywhere right so I got
to get it to work as many places I can
and just keep rounding those edges off
it's a it's a tough gig yeah it's like
putting a puzzle together yeah for sure
yeah but that puzzle might not work in
this room but it's the same pieces it's
[__] weird but that's why comedy's
hard I guess you ever get uh summer
money at the comedy Cafe what is that
mean they just pay you [__] they pay you
way less because it's the summer time
wow but here's the thing that you you
were talking about you're doing the same
hour you did in the winter but you're
getting paid less for it because the
sun's out even though it's packed right
man that's These are times where I'm not
I'm not selling any tickets this is
basically people are going to the club
right um but they you know they you're
but you're getting booked cuz they know
you're going to kill yeah and then they
tell you when you get there hey don't
know if they told you it's summer money
week what when you get there and it's
you know so they they want the same hour
but uh couldn't do it so you do you do
30 and then you spend a summer money
show and then you spend the last 15
telling a story that doesn't have an
ending and you get off stage you're like
what the [__] was that and like
Somerset dude you know uh cuz you can't
do that you can't as hard as your you
know you've been working but they all do
that I mean coming up now it's like I
pay people to book me on like local
radio shows and stuff cuz like it's in
my best interest to sell the tickets but
when you're getting a flat rate back in
the day right and and they're like three
shows Saturday uh morning radio uh 6:
a.m. pickup Friday morning you're like
all right condo condo and you're like
okay but this what's my motivation for
doing a six my motivation for selling
more tickets like obviously I want to
have more fans but like what's my
motivation when only you guys see a
benefit from it like it makes no sense
to me but and also you know that it
doesn't really help that much I know but
like now I do it just cuz I'm like [__]
it it's good to just be in the system I
guess I don't know and then when you you
start sorry when you start killing it
they're like remember when we helped you
and you're like [__] you put me
through the gauntlet oh that's every F
that was Mark and I were laughing our
ass off at JFL this year Montreal and uh
literally we're like having the most fun
just like you know we had the went to
Joe beef with Jo and an we're like you
know drinking martinis we're getting
[__] up and then we get to the
festival party and we're just getting
cornered by people who who [__] us out
of a bonus like 12 years ago like how
you been I'm like avoiding you for 12
years like I've avoided your text for 12
years you think I want to want to chill
I know I know you couldn't get an inch
without those blood suckers we were like
I see Mark across the room and it was
like I can't get the Mark I can't yeah
it was like walking dead you're like
whoa you're dodging
do you remember when I bumped you up
from 1,200 to
1300 after you'd been to my club five
times exactly the funny thing though is
when I was like brand new to the road
that meant so much to me and like I knew
clubs were like I remember doing like
this club uh now it's called dead crow
formerly was called nut street I was
getting paid jack [__] but he saw the
weekend and I did really well and he was
like I threw you a few x 100 and he
didn't have to do that so when you're a
young comic you're like holy [__] what
shout out Timmy appreciate
uh that type of stuff was like and also
that's a cool City Wilmington North
Carolina underrated City it's like a
weird New Orleans there they film I
think they film one of the Iron Man's
there they do it's a cool it's like a
cool Beach Town North Carolina's got
some cool Pockets
agreed I've never been but those bonuses
you're right when they don't have to but
then 10 years later you're doing the
math and you're like oh that 3% of what
he got yeah yeah but they weren't
killing it as a club it was it was stri
stly just him being like I appreciate it
you know and uh and that that goes such
a long way but I know what you mean when
they're crushing it see if that's still
there dead crow it's still there is it
okay good cuz that was a cool room
there's a clip of I think Lou on Conan
maybe and he's talking about Acme where
he did Acme and you know right when he
started blowing up and making money and
Lewis gave him a c like an envelope
filled with $10,000 cash for a bonus
because he sold out all the shows and
everybody rank a ton and so that kind of
you hear those stories and you're like
all right I mean when somebody gives you
that much money you go oh I'm about to
be on my way I think yes and you don't
forget that a headliner you remember
that guy Lou also has this story uh
where he I think he sold out every show
City in Austin and it's funny I have a
story about this guy too but he uh he
was like you got to do morning radio and
he goes I sold out every show why do I
have to do it and he goes you have to
and he was just like no and he's like
you got to do it or else and Lou just
kep saying no and he just showed up and
didn't do it and the guy was pissed but
he's like [__] you I saw I think about
that all the time cuz I remember I never
miss morning radio I never missed uh you
know TV or anything you got initials on
this
guy uh RM okay yeah but uh yeah you know
him but I remember I missed a morning TV
spot and I never did and I was like I
never I was like what the [__] happened
my [__] I used the iPhone alarm and
my iPhone broke so I didn't have an
alarm that's literally why I missed it I
I was like 10 minutes late and I was
like I'm running over I I'll do whatever
and they were like you missed it and he
wrote me this like long email like man
you like really screwed up man and I was
like I'm so sorry you know and then you
look back and you're like I had to
[__] gravel over over [__] morning
I [__] I never do that would have sold
one ticket maybe if anything those
morning TVs about to only help when we
when we throw a [__] wrench in the
tires you know exactly exactly you know
but uh yeah remember my my agent our all
of our former agent was like you got to
you got to send him a long apology note
y just like remember those days such a
silly business man but at the time
you're like I'll do whatever I got to do
you know and then there's uh there's a
club owner Columbus Ohio um his initials
Dave
Stroop and don't cut that because this
is a compliment okay I like Dave yeah I
I think he's fantastic great room I me
been invited to his kids graduations
like all that stuff his his boy came out
when I was in Denver once watching show
but uh I got fired from that place three
different times once the first of all
the staff brought me and I'm not blaming
them cuz I'm a grownup but they brought
me to the Michigan Ohio State game at
the Horseshoe and it was a three show
Saturday and so I just got [__]
wasted I got lost I tried to run back to
the club completely L they had to come
get me I was hammered when I got there
it was brutal so he's like okay you're
you're fired and I go yeah of course
fire myself self it's ridiculous and
then the next time I brought the staff
back to the condo and we were playing uh
um like toilet paper football where he
used toilet paper roll for the football
and everybody's just like hammered
having a great time but you know there
was blood on the carpet from knees and a
hole in the dry wall that kind of [__]
Kelsey cook was
working fire fired again yeah and then
uh somebody put uh Coca-Cola in the iron
and the next person there used it oh W
and it gummed up their pants and so
fired again but Dave was always like
here's the deal let's just let it calm
down a little bit and then I can bring
you back yeah he's he's one of those
guys where you know if he liked you or
if you had a history with him it was you
could [__] up but you I mean obviously
you had to apologize I don't think he
lik me toy sold tickets I cuz I remember
trying to work there as a feature and uh
he gave me like a oh by the way this is
you talking to uh Dave stoop when you
showed up drunk play that salak I'm not
fuel B
I've had a sip less than
you so [__] captivating I'm just like
I want to watch the whole thing now I
love that he was clearly drinking before
the interview and it less than you I
love him but uh feel my truth dude uh
yeah I remember he wrote me it was like
a polite rejection but it was like he he
did all right didn't hit it out of the
park or anything and then uh and then he
he he he someone else I forgot it was he
gave him a similar rejection he was like
yeah it was to slam dunk it was like it
was like oh it always a sports metaphor
you know yeah it couple things about
stro we we bonded once over breakfast
after morning radio like really got to
know each other he told me a Geraldo
story Geraldo of course famous drug
addict drunk crying in the Green Room
famous for being a great comic not
famous for being a drug addi one of the
best Comics ever we were I was talking
about how great he was and he's like I
got a story and I was like all right so
he's crying in the Green Room he's [__]
housed he's [__] up he's doing lines
the whole thing and he goes Geraldo
they're calling your name this place is
sold out they're here to see you you're
one of the best Comics working get out
there he's like I can't do it I can't do
it he's going through some [__] and he
goes you got to get out there and he
threw water on him picked him up threw
him on stage killed got a standing
ovation yeah that's like that's Showbiz
right there I know seems about right
that's
amazing he was like a king maker
remember everybody was like stro I'm
auditioning for Stroop it's all about
Stroop and he was like making breaking
people like American Idol remember Arty
Lang's Geraldo story where like I guess
Greg was was you know spiraling from
from you know the the stuff he was on
and they went to a roast and you know
Arty was like Greg was fre freaking out
apparently at the there's art story that
I'm paraphrasing he's freaking out at
the uh the airport he's like Art's like
I'm a drug addict I'll take care of you
I know what you need he's like literally
holding his hand through this [__] like
whatever I can do I'll help you like
already I love you man like you know
we're in this they're going to The
Comedy Central
Roast Greg somehow shows up he's looking
great he's like the hair is slick back
he's looking awesome his opening line
Arty Lang you fat [__] drug addict
and he just turns to him like
this that's comedy the show's got to go
on I got to get
laughs and if your feelings are going to
get hurt that's the
breaks yeah he's the [__] best he he
was one of the best Comics ever I mean
oh yeah I'm a I'm a big fan unbelievable
did you ever meet Geraldo I did worked
with him at the comedy Cafe that's where
I met him when I did my audition guest
set to get work there he was he was
headlining W there you go yeah he was
that was a comedy was a different thing
back then it was felt more Niche kind of
underground kind of rough around the
edges like all the comics were like
heroin addicts and drunks and now half
of them are dead it was like a wild west
back then and now it's there wasn't as
much of a like it was harder to find
success back then because like look at
where we find success is through social
media and stuff like that and these guys
were doing like they were doing the same
[__] as us it just wasn't reaching as
many people cuz you know say Greg would
crush on Conan or Letterman like that
was just gone you that night to see it
yes yeah I mean my to to get work I was
sending out VHS tapes I had a master and
then I would go V uh VCR to vcr and make
a bunch of these six minute audition
tapes and send them out there you go I
did that cuz the comic strip was like
they only had a VHS machine so you put
in that you'd have to go to the CVS and
you get you put in a tape yeah God the
[__] I cringe to see myself oh we got
to find those yeah we sure do we got to
find those tapes yeah just embarrassing
yeah I had the CD like a little DVD like
the ones you write on you know yeah that
was my thing I found one of my old ones
from Indianapolis and I was doing this
bit about how uh this guy had just been
killed by his his wife beat him to death
with a frying pan and I was like uh you
know something like what is she a
cartoon and I'm crawling across the
stage and it's like physical comedy and
I'm watching it and I'm like if I get up
to take if I get up to press stop on
this I might walk right to the kitchen
and slit my throat so I just sit on the
couch until the the shame went away it
was [__] brutal damn those old sets
are tough you're like how did I even
think that was good what was going
through my head you you sound weird you
look weird you're moving weird the well
you're taking chances cuz you don't know
who you are yet so you're like like am I
a physical dude you just are kind of
doing what you like and I liked all
kinds of Comedy so I like know who the
[__] I am like you know you watch like
Jim Carrey you watch Eddie Murphy you're
like well I don't know who I am but can
you explain why my voice was an octave
higher I mean I had gone through puberty
but I was just like maybe this will get
you yeah I mean it was [__] so gross
that was the same way I'm like sweating
thinking about it oh yeah I remember one
of my first jokes was uh this is going
to get get the the knife out cuz this
might get ugly I would say uh you know
they say when something's hard it's no
picnic hey that that uh math test was no
picnic but picnics are easy you get some
uh some food together a
blanket
picnic there's your
bit but no no the the joke is that was
it different than that well I mean a
picnic is easy so it does make sense
wait maybe it was the other way that's
no picnic cuz yeah picnic's but my my
joke was picnics are actually hard you
got to get food together a basket you
got to go go out there's an ant there in
the wood you get bitten picnic suck the
Sun's shining that was the bit and it
was like this is back when from when
picnics were cool I know I know but I
when people like picnics I just thought
you had to be the 80s guy like what's up
with this this is weird you can hear
somebody's first joke and you can go you
start in
909 right right well you just are
watching [__] like I mean I remember
like watching I'd like rent whatever I
could see it be like you know YouTube
wasn't a thing like that so you just
like okay I guess uh I'll I'll try to
find an evening at the impro impr DVD
and now you're doing an impression of
like [__] Dennis
wolfberg teacher of the year yeah that's
true teacher of the year he was [__]
funny he was funny he was really funny I
remember staying up for evening at The
Improv and it would come on and they'd
show him in in the beginning and be like
all right I'll watch until he's on yeah
cuz some of the people you'd seen and
you're like I could do without this but
pull up some wolfberg there's got to be
some greatest it's going to be a
20-minute setup I remember being in I
remember being in college and just
you're like like Comics unleash you're
like all right who is it yeah and if
it's like someone you really like you
stick it out but then some of I mean
that show Mark's got the best Comics un
leash
story and they retain enough order to
qualify for federal
assistance they grow vericose veins that
make their legs look like road
maps and they pee 80 90 times a day I'm
telling you my wife she peed around the
clock or any other appliance that happen
to be within hey that's funny was
unbelievable the incredible degree of
pain that she would do
and she would wake up every morning
nauseous with morning sickness and
wretching and gagging and and she'd
complain and I'd say but sweetheart
you're
glowing imagine this is your biology
teacher and he just makes it on you're
like what the [__] Mr wilberg well that
just happened to someone didn't it
someone didn't someone get in trouble
for that recently being a standup yeah
there was like a story he got in trouble
he like appealed his firing because he
was like my stand Up's actually good oh
I didn't like a story but Dennis
wolfberg man he's like and so if you
want a balloon to rise you have to get
the
I mean that would be the weirdest
teacher to have I know I know he's a
cook but that we've come so far with
comedy cuz it's like cool now we got you
get you see wolfberg to Matt re it's
funny how it's like that was a comic
like a weird looking guy who's there
still Comics like him who it's just who
are like him I don't know there's
comedians who are I mean I love that
kind of style I like that old uh I think
there are a lot of comedians that aren't
you know that goodlooking and kind of
weirdish stuff none in this room all
right
they uh I think they it is harder
probably now cuz you're like it's so
visual they're like are you can we cast
you in something I was like well I guess
you almost have to be like really fat or
really exactly it you can't be just like
that right right but like Louie Anderson
or John Panet like these were the comics
I watched growing up oh man I just
watched John Pet's youo now oh my God
it's one of the best bits it is Iconic
iconic comedy
if you look it up on here they so they
what they had to do for the clip is you
know how they take out all the laughter
and get to the next thing so he just
looks like a full ass
racist cuz the because it's so endearing
when you watch it live he was a murderer
I remember when I did like a bringer
show uh I was like a young comic doing a
bringer show and he was like one of the
special guests and my mom sat through
some [__] bad my mom wanted to see me
and she saw through some [__] bad
comedy and then she was like all right
he saved it he was really good oh there
you go she also sat through uh Rich Voss
went on and he he called he called a
woman in the crowd he goes Miss look at
you you're a two on a
Tuesday my mom was like who was that
repulsive
Man actually really funny guy he's funny
but you got to like Shield your mom from
him like don't talk about her if you
talk about your mom you tase his ass
yeah man pette used to people used to
bring panette full cheesecakes from the
Cheesecake Factory wow it was wild
that's not good no it but it was it was
[__] crazy but it's funny cuz this
guy is so sweet you worked with him
sweet guy and Dearing guy nice guy
Asians love him but now this would just
be just torn up to pieces like this is
so like him with one of the
cheesecakes yeah right so you're like he
let it uh I sounded Asian there but you
know let it let it lie a little you know
like the it's in the intent know we
should just attack people also [__]
changes like what you can say
comedically is going to change that's
fine like you know comedy will evolve
and yeah and guess what if you're going
up to the line with a bit you're going
to have some [__] misfires fine yeah
and I also think right this he wrote
this in ' 80s late 80sa and so I do
think you you should have to
apply the you know what the rules of
that time to whatever you're doing cuz
now if you see this now you're like well
[__] that's why I love the movie Birth
of a Nation you know I think
uh but no yeah you gota it's like going
hey this milk is one cent you're like
well yeah that was right 1904 yeah
things change you really do you have to
yeah you have to think about what was
going on in the world at the time of
course you can't just watch it through
today's lens that's insane you know yeah
but sometimes it feels like people want
to drum it up just like we need
something to ruin you know so let's go
back to John Wayne you're like well he's
been dead yeah what are we doing here I
think people fear happiness and joy I
think so too I think if you don't have a
problem to work on you can't just sit
there and enjoy the happiness you found
you got to find something to pick apart
or you're going to go crazy fun is bad
people don't like fun they sure don't
tell somebody you had a good day and see
how that [__]
goes that's literally like a like
studies people post that they're happy
on Instagram like makes you sad oh if
someone's like just got a promotion to
work I got a great wife I love my kid
you're like [__] this [__] right
you like you hate that guy that's like
every study is like their happiness but
if you see someone sad it does you're
like all right I don't know if it's more
like I'm not alone or what I don't think
we're like Monsters like good someone
suffering but I think it's more like you
know okay things are tough it's funny to
say that this Gypsy Rose you hearing
about this she killed the mom and all
that I was just in Springfield oh jeez
yeah so that's that's their claim to
fame I'm going how is that blue room
yeah it's good okay yeah well point
being I'm watching going this is [__]
horrific but I'm like man I feel better
about my [__] up life you know like
all the [__] I've done and said I'm like
all right I'm not that I'm not killing
the mom that's pretty good yeah so there
is something to that well there there's
actually studies been done about like uh
countries that have a harsh winter and
are dark a lot of the year have less
suicide than sunny places because when
you're all in the dark you're like well
at least there are people commiserating
with me but when you're sad and it's
sunny and you see people having fun
around you and you still don't find that
Joy that's when it's like Hawaii suicide
is high in Hawaii that's interesting but
also suicide is also high in Seattle
upstate New York are bad weather places
but Seattle they so SE Minnesota gets
less Sunshine than Seattle per year I
think they say there's so much rain cuz
it rains every day but it just rains for
like 15 minutes interesting so I don't
want to listen Seattle people keep your
emails to yourself it's yeah well I
don't want to get too sad here but some
some queef made a compilation of or a
side by side of 2022 New Year's big ball
drop and then
2024 and it's quite a difference because
I think fun is is weird now fun is out
so like 2002 they're
like happy New Year they're making out
they're kicking balloons they're having
a great time and then this one was like
happy New Year there it is there it
is and look it's not the starkest
contrast but oh look at this yeah the
kissing there balloons everywhere hey
that was a gross ass kiss a little bit
were they birds that was your brother
and sister maybe well you can do that
then look at those people though
confetti they're going AP [__] where is
this I think it's all over yeah it's
like Tokyo and Manhattan and there I
think they were still just happy that
ytk didn't happen lost right oh okay
this just today this is today just some
guy slid in his
wrist that's a sad kiss look at that no
movement no confetti no balloons nothing
it's and it's somber the music is sad
yeah I mean what's going on we're not
allowed to have fun fun is John's not
even playing his piano he was there who
was the guy singing on New Year's uh
[__] you know God I can't believe I'm
forgetting his name he was on he's one
of the Time Square guys singing he's one
of those like old school rap guys yeah
yeah Tony Bennett no no uh I think he
died oh [__] Tony Bennett did die right
yeah I think so [__] he was cool he was
good he was kind of the last of that era
no this guy you know what I'm talking
about bé no 80 years old he had a
beautiful wife too yeah she was a
[__] nice piece oh pull up pull up
the wife
yeah let's get it all going here you
know what I'm talking about what's his
[__] name I want to say alen Arin
that's obviously not he's saying my way
and stuff yeah hot wife it's not working
it's like a Sinatra impersonator no he's
got his own songs he's got songs you've
heard before too all right wasn't bé
though God damn it you couldn't find my
Matumbo clip you can't find this you're
[__] slipping is it um is it uh not
uh what's that guy's name Jason morz no
he's got Justine and Jason baitman was
it Jason bait's wife's dad you know who
that is no Jesus he he like wrote a
bunch of songs for Sinatra but was also
a singer oh you'll know his name if you
if you ever pull just play the Cat
Williams clip again yeah but point being
we're sad or now we're not allowed to
have fun there you go let me see I'm
trying to find it out M yeah it is sad
it's a bummer why can't we why is fun
out Paul Anka Anka that's who it is
that's who I was talking about really
you know this one your dad yeah no
[__] way he's Canadian right I I
guess so almost POS us that's right cut
Sam's
mic put your hand on my
shoulder I know it yeah all right yeah
he's good
Anka ankor man boy's little are you sure
that's his
[Laughter]
wife
wo is he Canadian yeah
if this at least if this is who I'm
thinking almost positive I like an looks
like a keer elf right there he he wrote
my
way four Frank Sinatra he was like 16
years old when he came down here look
how sad this is 16 years old and he
wrote all those songs before he was 18
wow so he's set for life he's a zillion
oh big time inad he's cute let's look
ahead all right well look this is this
is a bummer yeah it should be confet
should be [__] guitars and drums and
horns I think three people commit
suicide since we played this segment
this is how I do comedy when people
don't laugh at my jokes I just
stop H this is you talking about the
life of David
Gail all right where are you going to be
here what do we got some tour dates
cooking there with new material I think
so yeah I just was talking about being
Tempe and I'll be uh at the Blue Room in
Springfield Missour and I'm going to be
over at Bricktown in Oklahoma City I got
all those right there nice yeah love
Bricktown and then I'm taping a
recording a new special March 2nd St
Paul Fitzgerald theater and that'll be
real fun I think oh baby the Twin Cities
love it let me let me throw on uh let me
throw this on I got a couple podcasts I
got uh middle of somewhere with my buddy
saigh and then Kelsey and I started a
podcast Kelsey cook and I it's called
pretend problems we just do it from the
place hell yeah nice you got to have a
pod these days have to uh tell Sai I
said hello I will he's a good
egg what do you got Sammy baby I don't
know what when does this come out next
this week right all right so I got what
do I have we got uh January 18 oh we
added a show in
Stanford uh same night don't want to
spend any more time in Connecticut uh
Dania Beach that'll be a fun one the
following weekend Omaha love love that
club the funny bone uh Addison
Improv that's a good one yeah then we
got OKC Bricktown as well Irvine Salt
Lake City and then new special at the
Wilbur so it's already sold out I think
that's looking good exciting as [__]
nice that'll be nice yeah yeah have fun
building that new brand new hour I'm not
looking forward to it because this is
it's it's fun doing well on stage it's
nice and then you're like oh I got to
[__] eat [__] for another year yeah
Seinfeld always says it you feel like
when you have a good hour you feel like
you're going out there with fully loaded
with banders and you're like I'm killing
everybody in this [__] and then have no
material you're like I got a pocket
knife yeah exactly I have my hour almost
whittel down and I was in Arlington
recently Arlington Virginia and I was
there right after I recorded the
specials yeah the two specials and uh
this lady comes up to me after she goes
I was here last time too you were better
this time it's like yeah no [__] it's
tough I came out here with just notes
damn at least that ended positively that
can go either way well the hard thing is
you got to they don't get like you if
that's also why we have a healthy amount
of self-hatred because if you're if
you're turning over hours you're going
to bomb and be like [__] me totally you
know but if you're just killing all the
time those are the people that are like
I'm [__] great you have to have that'
80s gym teacher voice in your head like
oh you [__] you suck get back up fix
this [__] joke or you got Twi
push-ups coming the amount of f- word I
call myself in my head is disturbing the
gym teacher
gay I had a gym teacher uh a baseball
coach he was the [__] funniest guy he
literally sounded like George Carlin it
was like I when I think of you guys
trying to turn a double play it's always
when I'm wiping my ass it was like [__]
like that he was just just like he got
fired cuz he was just too he would do
that too much but like we were all like
you can't fire this guy he's [__]
great we were yeah he was the best yeah
coach Suds sudsy what do you got I can't
see my dates here to show Chad that
these two had breakfast I saw that
actually right when I got off the
elevator my Instagram pop back up and it
was the first first pick on there the
amount of people that I text me
immediately I posted that it was
like holy [__] what was breakf you know
it's crazy how fast the internet works
all right makes you not want to post
doesn't it I know I feel like Cat
Williams I can't imagine what his phone
was
doing holy [__] can you imagine oh my
God and they ain't going to stop anytime
soon no no but he'll sell out nine
Arenas in one night yeah all right I'm
in Tampa this weekend oh that's already
over all right uh basically come on out
to Columbus Dave Stroop say hello hello
let's get breakfast Indianapolis the
beacon second show or we're almost sold
out of that second one so get tickets
quick if they're not gone by now
Lexington Charlotte San Anton Houston
Boise Salt Lake Atlanta Raleigh Austin
Tucson Phoenix Charlottesville
Charleston El Paso you know what it is
Mark Norman comedy.com get some Bodega
cat Bodega cat whiskey.com love doing
the paper plane worked out evener was
great
that's that's like one of our top we
have like we have our top whiskey drinks
in paper plane I feel like I feel like
we played a part in popularizing that
one oh 100% it's gotten really popular
and uh that Manhattan's boulevardier
like we're we're whiskey forward [__] uh
cocktail guys for sure I make an
oldfashioned with black walnut bitters
Maple maple syrup instead of the sugar
and then I put a little bacon stir stick
in there that sounds [__] awesome
pretty good when it's real cold that
sounds like a Minnesota
that sounds awesome maybe we'll do that
next time you're here hell yeah let's do
it'll the I'll bring the stuff the Chad
Daniels all right well yeah check out
Chad special Sally you good Peter's
Gotham
Studios Paul Anka still alive and uh try
to try to uh lighten up everybody let's
let's get out of this [__] Funk we're
in it's a new year bad as [__] I know
January is also kind of a sad month for
a lot of people I feel like cuz it's
like you're over the hump the holidays
can be depressing then you kind of pass
that and you're like another year of
this [__] some people it's a reset but
other people it's like another year of
this [__] yeah so pick it up but try to
try to find something good there's good
good stuff going on I don't know like
the W even the balloon waving is sad
it's all i' like to see some uh and the
sex doesn't matter here but I'd like to
see some [__]
2025 I would and some more sucking on
both ends men women send you some links
everyone get a little more sucking going
yeah sucky sucky that's my that's our
love language
yeah we'll see you
now hey fun
[Music]
stuffo
and's down in the same
way up on the roof like a cop coming and
naked Samuel is feeling
dangerous I'm out to lunch here in New
Orleans this woman doesn't look like I
remember and I get down in the
same we
might
be
true